hello everyone and welcome to game 10 of
the world Chase championship match
between yaniponishi and the dingliren at
the score is uh 5.4 yeah and four points
for Ding and ding now has the wide
pieces he will try to win the game to
equalize the score and then uh hopefully
uh even take a lead in the match because
so far only Jan's been taking the lead
and the ding has been equalizing now
this is already game 10 I know it feels
like the the championship started like
yesterday but already nine incredible
games haven't played okay the Berlin
defense one the previous one wasn't all
that spectacular uh but the first date
uh truly incredible so here we will have
a sort of a repetition from game four
but an early deviation from it and ding
opens with Ponta C4 he again goes for
the English opening and of course uh as
I did it in every video I hear the first
ceremonial move was made by none other
than console Zakaria she's the president
of the National Academy of Science of
Kazakhstan and the developer of
kazakhstan's Casco with uh vaccine so
there we have that first move being
played I don't know what she played it's
a sort of a weird angle but uh does not
that doesn't look like like she
made it a C4 so let's just say ding
retracted it and uh then he just played
C4 so there you have it uh and the Yan
replies the same as he did in game four
we have Knight to F6 Knight to C3 and
now Pawn to E5 we have Knight to F3 and
knights the C6 the Four Knights of the
English are on the board and here I'm in
game three we had Pawn to E3 but here
ding goes for the early Pawn to E4 and
um it's uh very interesting that uh ding
will actually be playing a game uh nepo
played three years ago in title Tuesday
with the white pieces so I I don't know
how much of that nepo actually remembers
when he's playing this game or is it
some sort of his preparation that he
used for something years ago uh but it
is it is very interesting and here uh
the top movies Bishop the B4 with Bishop
to C5 and now Knight captures on E5 this
makes it possible because the bishop is
on C5 the bishop on B4 would not allow
this and you have uh basically one good
option here you could play something in
morphe's style like castles but a
standard way to play this is Knight
captures on E5 I know you guys are
wondering but what about Bishop captures
nf2 can we just mess up white spawn
structure and then capture back the
piece well you could the problem is
after Knight captures it looks like
you've achieved something but you really
don't have anything after D4 your pieces
are just weird even if you give this
check the white king is perfectly happy
and G1 and now how do you continue let's
say D6 you want to develop something but
there's no way to bring more pieces into
the attack white will just kick away
your knight and after we move the Knight
Bishop G5 and it's a very uh bad bad
position for black not a lot to do here
if you ever Castle White can always just
capture mess up your Pawn structure
we're gonna play Bishop D3
um move the king play Rook to F1 you can
artificially Castle you can do whatever
you want here so that's why Knight
captures an E5 is the main move here we
have quantity for winning back the piece
and now Bishop goes the the main Square
basically the V4 Square D captures an E5
Knight captures an E4 and now not Queen
to D4 but rather Queen to F3 ding plays
all the moves uh Jan played in that
title to the game that we've mentioned
uh Knight captures on c3b characters
chasing away the bishop and now uh there
are many Retreats possible here uh much
like in the Evans gun between the bishop
and B4 is challenged by playing C3 you
can go Bishop to A5 you can go Bishop to
C5 you can go Bishop to E7 you can even
go Bishop to f8 and it makes sense in
some lines because the queen wants to
come to G3 and put pressure on that pawn
here Jan plays Bishop to C5 and this is
uh that rare movie it's uh only been
played a handful of times plus in that
one game Jan played online and here we
have uh Queen to G3 of course the inputs
pressure on the G7 pawn and now King the
f8 and this is uh necessary uh just to
give you an idea of what's happening if
you Castle Bishop to G5 and now you
can't really move the queen because the
bishop F6 and you're just lost uh or
close to Lost uh so after Bishop D7 uh
Bishop to H6 now threatens Checkmate and
after G6 you will play Pawn to H4 Pawn
to H5 open up the H file and so on white
will have a very nice attack very early
on in the game
so after G3 nepo just played King to f8
uh and uh as he does play the French
with the black pieces I'm sure he's no
stranger to putting his King on a f8 and
it can be such an annoying move to to
meet when you play White uh but okay
here we have Bishop T2 you could also
consider some other moves like Bishop to
D3 for Bishop to G5 even attack the
queen but here it's not so impressive
because the queen just moves Queen E8
and you don't have anything here because
the king is not on G8 so instead Bishop
to E2 nicely developing uh and now uh uh
Pawn to D6 Nepal challenges dings a
Central Pawn here and the situation on
the clock is an hour and 30 minutes for
Ding and an hour and 56 minutes for
Nepal so Nepal basically blitzed all of
this out he is not even thinking here
with Bishop to F4 biting now Queen to E7
and now Rook to D1 just putting more
pressure on that D6 pawn and apple just
plays Pawn to H5 he says if you Castle
now uh could be could be a little bit
dangerous but if you go for something
like Queen Bishop G5 then it could be
even more dangerous and there are so
many awesome lines here look at this in
Bishop G5 you can never capture here
because after Queen captures and phone
captures this will just be Checkmate
that's mating one so what you will have
to do here after Bishop G5 is actually
play F6 and this is something that the
dink can go for for example captures and
captures and you go back Bishop to E3 it
looks like you've done a lot uh but uh
who is really attacking here that's the
question after Rook the G8 attacks the
Queen the queen has to move somewhere uh
otherwise you lose the G2 Pawn so it's
the bishop to H6 check first king F7 now
you move the queen let's say queen to D3
now even Rook to G6 you don't want to
allow Queen to H7 checks or Rook to G6
and now let's Bishop back to E3 black
will trade captures captures in Bishop
to G4 black solves all of his problems
and it might even be white uh who who
has problems playing this position so
while it looks like an incredible idea
uh F6 for black will be uh very strong
here so here uh being just castled and
it is in fact now as of move 14 that we
have a completely new game and in this
um with this move ding deviates from the
game that nepo played and interestingly
in that game uh Jan faced H5 uh he just
challenged it with H4 uh so that's how
young continued Yan won that game very
nicely uh against
um uh Jose Cabrillo cardoso but here we
have castles and now we have Ponte H4
Bayan just challenging that Queen we
have Queen D3 now you could also play
Queen to F3 it's a fine square but it
asks a lot of questions for example D
captures Bishop captures Queen captures
Rook to d8 with check what is what is
happening here after King the E7 Rook
captures on h8 there's this very nasty
Bishop to G4 move and now you don't
really have enough to give up the queen
for example if you play Rook capture
sunny on A8 Bishop captures and F3
Bishop captures okay you have two Rooks
for the queen but let's say I'm like H3
or a more like G5 and it does maybe that
doesn't feel sufficient uh so you know
black black would be better here what
you could do is after this bishop to G4
move just play Queen captures and G4 and
okay then Rook captures back on h8
you're not down the exchange and this is
uh again very much playable but it still
feels like black is getting too much out
of this so ding just play the Queen to
D3 and now we have Pawn to G5 by on uh
you could also consider some other moves
like Bishop T E6 let's say Pawn to H3
right away but Ian basically forces a
queen trade with the spawn to G5 move
and okay ecat person D6 I don't think
ding was happy with the queen trade here
because Jan is accepting being down upon
if he goes into the end game uh but it's
the best that the ding can take out of
the position after G5 has been played so
see capture C captures Bishop captures
with Queen captures on D6 Queen captures
Bishop captures and Rook captures and
finally after this capture Fest is over
trip to E6 and okay Jan is down a pawn
but uh he will no longer be under any
pressure he can get his Rooks into the
game and he has the double C Pawn to
play against so ding also has some
issues to take care of and he plays
Ponte for of course he wants to open up
the file to go after the black king and
the the situation on the clock is evened
out a little bit uh ding has an hour and
seven minutes on the clock where Asian
has an hour and 15 minutes on the clock
and okay King 37 of course yeah knows
that Bing will open up the f file so you
don't want the King on the f file
attacking The Rook here also Rook to D4
with G captures on F4 uh you can't
really play G4 if you play G4 although
you know it looks maybe interesting F5
just blunders a pawn so not not
happening so instead G captures on F4 we
have Rook captures on F4 but not uh yeah
yeah Rook captures and F4 you can also
play Disco captures but there's really
nothing to do on the f file uh Ponte H3
and now of course spawn to G4 and now
the real question is okay dink has the
uh weak sea pawns here but his bishop
and the Rooks are nicely defending that
can he uh in any way go after the H3
Pawn how could he win the H3 Pawn well
one way to do it is you could just trade
all the Rooks and the bishop uh and then
just you know play King F2 King G3 and
pick up that pawn if he can do that then
he of course will win the game he's
gonna have a king and pawn end game he's
gonna be up upon the problem is Nepal
will of course never allow the trade of
everything so here we have Rook 8 to C8
uh uh an interesting approach was Rook 8
the G8 definitely uh looks looks fine
here and after King to F2 there's even
Pawn to F5 but it's a bit too too over
ambitious for black the problem is after
g-captors and this Rook the G2 check is
given King the E3 Rook captures an H2
the problem is Rook F to E4 you will not
capture right away that would be that
terrible but you will first play this
and now you will capture with check and
now even if black plays something like
Rook captures on E2 with check and King
cap percent H2 it seems like okay you're
you know doing okay here there's Rook
captures on E6 check and after King F7
you will just pick up the rook and h8 to
Rook the D7 with check now you have to
go to the back ranking a fair work today
would check King to G7 and now you
either uh you know best is the just kick
away the king or King King to H7 and now
you can play Rook to D7 with Checkmate
so okay black keeps the rule keeps the
pawn on H2 but he gets checkmated so uh
although a nice idea to go for something
like Rook 8 to G8 and Ponte F5 It could
only lead to trouble so nepo keeps it
calm just a nice Rook to C8 putting
pressure on the C4 pawn and also he
wants to get his Rook into the game
somehow another way to do it maybe uh
would be to play Rook the H6 Rook to F6
and then try to get this Rook into the
game this way but okay King F2 biting
with Rook the C5 now uh and uh Pawn to
A4 we have rooked the A5 putting
pressure on the pawn here ending just
plays Bishop to D1 and and okay things
Bishop doing a fine job here guarding G4
guarding A4 so not a lot to worry about
here and again nipple could go for some
Rook A6 Rook to B6 Rook to B two ideas
maybe again Rook H6 to F6 it's all
possible but for just goes for a nice
com B6 no need to rush anything uh King
to G3 by Ding and now Rook to H6 for the
moment this Rook cannot move because you
will lose this Pawn uh but uh it's it's
dinku has to figure out what to play
here Jan is basically just waiting if
ding wants a draw or he will try to
actually win this um uh up upon position
and the situation on the clock is ding
invested some 20 minutes on this game
the G3 move he couldn't find any other
way how to improve his position he's
down to 38 minutes nipple has in an hour
on the clock so here Rook F to E4 and
now King to f8 of course you do not want
your uh King on on the file Rook the D5
could be very annoying so it just came
to a f8 and now rooked the d8 with check
again you can't go back because because
then Rook to D5 again so King to G7 was
played and now Rook to A8 I didn't put
pressure on that A7 pawn and now Rook
the C5 just offering a trade here you
could go for some tricky lines like
Bishop to D7 which puts pressure on A4
then we get Rook to E7 attacks the
bishop and now Rook to D6 defends the
bishop and now let's say Bishop to F3
came to F6 chases away The Rook Rook to
E3 and now Rook captures an H uh an A4
and King captures an H3 so we could have
this trade where we would have the a
pawn against the H Pawn as sort of a
race a race type game but nepo decides
to go for Rook to C5 he wants something
a little less double edged so Rook
captures an A7 and now Bishop captures
and C4 Rook captures isn't very good
because afterward captures Bishop
captures
um it's uh not gonna be easy to hold on
to you have two weaknesses the H3 pawn
and this pawn and let's say you put the
bishop somewhere like here you put the
bishop on C6 you put the Rook on CC six
and you trade of the Rooks then then
this Pawn is weak then then this Pawn
Falls and uh White will have excellent
winning chances here uh so instead just
Bishop captures on C4 by nipple Rook 8
to A7 doubling up on the E file and now
Rook H to C6 everyone thought nipple
would just play uh Bishop D6 here
because it looks very nice this this
coordinate is the white uh Rooks but
there's this very annoying fantasy for
move where you have to be very careful
because if you play Rook captures on C4
then you run into this very nasty Rook
captures on E6 move and you can resign
you just blunder the piece here uh so
what do you have you what you would have
to do is Bishop captures and then
something like Rook to E5 and the game
continues like zero captures Rook
captures Rook to D6 Bishop to E2 offers
a trade of Bishop to captures captures
Rook to D3 check King H4 and Rook to B3
and you would have uh this type of um
position so it's definitely possible but
you have to uh you know calculate a lot
after Pawn to C4 so Nepal just keeps it
uh calm he just doubles up here goes
after the weak C3 Pawn Rook 7 to E5 and
now uh nepo just trades real characters
real characters we have Bishop to B3
incredible nipple blunder is a bishop
here uh of course that is a joke uh uh
an apple can always win it back with the
Rook captures on C3 and that is exactly
what happened here Bishop captures on B3
there is no more way for ding to push
for Advantage here we have a check here
King to H4 Rook captures on B3 and now
with equal material it's not going to be
a hard The Rook the B5 was played Rook
to A3 of course uh if you trade it then
a white will just win the game even
though for the moment it's equal
material you will lose the H3 pawn and
then the H Pawn just marches the victory
so we have to keep the Rook Rook to A3
we have Rook counters and B6 Rook
captures on A4 and now King characters
on H3 so Nepal is down upon but this is
an elementary Rook end game and nepo
does not mind showing everyone how it's
done with Ponte F5 he even gives up
another Pawn but he knows that he will
win it back and then he's just done one
Pawn in a rook end game and that's a
draw pretty much always but not always
so G captures on F5 was played G5 uh
doesn't really do all that much just
Rook to G4 and you're gonna win it back
this way so here just captures on F5 we
have Rook the F4 and now Rook the B5
being defended but now just King to F6
and you will win back of course your
Pawn King to G3 was played Rook captures
on F5 Rook captures King captures now
upon the H4 uh King to G6 and nipple uh
ding just a fonte H5 check gave up the
last remaining um upon on the board
never played King captures on H5 and was
in this position animal 45 that the game
ended in a draw as it is a draw by
insufficient material
uh so there we have it very nicely done
adding uh really tried the surprise
nipple with this one again going for the
English but the yarn was just too
prepared he like he played the first 20
moves with like five five minutes on the
clock so yeah not not gonna happen in
English it would seem for the even
though okay he won game four with the
English it was a spectacular game uh but
Ian said uh not so fast not not
um another time so we'll see what
happens in the next one where Jan will
have the white pieces will we have again
the the ruy Lopez will uh it's hard to
say it's hard for me to imagine the ding
will go for another Berlin because he
needs the bonds back in the match and he
uh barely got even you know some
playable moves in the last game where he
went for the Berlin so he's gonna have
to go for morphe's defense he's gonna
have to go for A6 and uh well we can
only hope that we get a marshall but uh
you know I I I don't think it will
happen so probably some sort of a weird
anti-martial position again everything
is to look for uh for winning chances
but if you haven't seen my yesterday's
video do check it out if you are
interested in a very cool martial
attacking game between John Nunn and uh
vishwanathan
uh so yeah that's the game I hope you
guys enjoyed it I would like to thank
given Mana Barry mcmurdock Mackwell
Maxwell Shirley uh yonding Gutierrez and
Paul says for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here and thank
you all for watching and I will see you
soon continuing the coverage of the
World Chess Championship until it
finishes tomorrow we are continuing with
the game 11. uh so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day